sa visite n'aura durée que quelques
heures mais cela aura suffi à marquer
les esprits pour son premier déplacement
à l'étranger depuis le début de la
guerre volodime ski est venu à
Washington pour remercier les États-Unis
de leur soutien face au Congrès le
président ukrainien a offre ce drapeau
signé par les soldats sur le front et
réclame davantage d'être
oui
nous avons l'artillerie c'est vrai et je
vous remercie
sac honnêtement pas vraiment
votre argent n'est pas de la charité
c'est un investissement dans la sécurité
et la démocratie internationale que nous
gérons de la façon la plus responsable
possible
ne repart pas les mains vides les
parlementaires américains sont sur le
point de voter une nouvelle enveloppe de
soutien à l'Ukraine de près de 45
milliards de dollars une aide qui vient
s'ajouter aux 50 milliards de dollars
déjà fournis par Washington dont 20
milliards en armement quelques instants
plus tôt le président ukrainien a
rencontré Joe bye de Na la Maison
Blanche le président américain a donné
son accord pour l'envoi de missile
anti-aérien nous allons continuer de
renforcer les capacités de défense
ukrainienne et particulièrement la
défense aérienne
c'est pourquoi nous allons fourni à
l'Ukraine des batteries de missiles
patriotes et nous formerons vos forces
pour les utiliser correctement
une aide bienvenue pour Kiev alors que
sur le terrain les combats sans lisent
l'armée russe pilonne la région de
barmut Alès et cible les infrastructures
ukrainiennes engendrant des coupures de
gaz et d'électricité